oh hello there
you may be wondering why the pink suit
so the world can see that I have a big
ol heart on that's heart with the T for
my new obsession pink the color not the
pop singer personally I'm more of a
saline kind of guy
pink is hide like a beautiful ribbon to
a cause very close to me cancer so
amazed and I are joining together scare
up some serious cash for [ __ ] cancer I'm
gonna donate the very suit off my back
while giving you a chance to own some
movie marketing memorabilia what you do
from there is limited only by your
imagination will you add it to your
weekly wardrobe rotation who doesn't
become a colorful addition to your S&M
dungeon all you simply nail it to a post
in order to scare away birds children
and the elderly visit the website below
to get all the details this is one fight
where everyone can be a hero no
superpowers capes or lame CG costumes
needed just your money seriously we need
that these suits aren't cheap
Adam acecomm forward slash Deadpool and
together let's f cancer calm
[Music]
whoa you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care auditor stronk eyes
beautiful
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in a
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you missed me read
what in the ass
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid movie guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be he needs you
lot smarter than I look
I am lettin cable kill this kid I can't
do this alone
we're gonna form a super-duper group
that's what we're gonna be
forward-thinking gender neutral you will
be known as x-force isn't that a little
derivative you're absolutely right now
cue the music
tell me they got that in slow motion
doing the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right sometimes
fight dirty
that is why the man bun is just a
millennial mullet oh oh god I wish I
finished college it lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably want me to make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it
[Music]